[Music]
[Applause]
and
today i feel like my entire life
just opened up i basically am in wizard
of oz i'm dorothy
i left the black and white and i just
walked into technicolor
listen to me about this this is a
bouquet this is the dried flowers it's a
company called
urban stems now you guys do you ever
want to send people flowers around the
country
and you're freaking out about like a
good local forest
or is it going to come out okay like
this is very stressful to me i
understand yeah all the time
this company goes all over the country
and you can do beautiful fresh flowers
dried flowers you can do little plants
and cactuses and succulents
this is so chic it's so
of this world and time and life and you
can totally clock it
and it's so elevated and well done and
yet it's accessible
and i've been waiting for something like
this my whole life i love this you can
send dried flowers like this yeah and
you can pick your container
really yeah and it's curated by
different they have different collabs
with people who they did one with vogue
with vogue with like a cool
octagonal black one there it's it's very
chic it's
very chic and for the first time in my
life urban stems
has like i said changed my life to
technicolor so i love these so much
and we have a very special thing to tell
you which is we're gonna send them to
our very special drew gooders that are
on the show which is people that we
shine a light on
who are just making the world a better
place and being the human example to us
all so drew getters are getting this
care of urban stem
across the entire country so thank you
to urban stem and where have you been
all my life
um i just want to thank jill and rossi
for hanging out today this really was a
valentine's day treat
happy valentine happy valentine's day
love you guys what are you doing for
valentine's day
we're going to vermont you are yeah it's
winter wonderland right now it really is
rossi
uh i'll be um celebrating valentine's
day
you know yes it's a happy time for me
i'll be alone yeah i was just gonna ask
i'll be alone
eating carbohydrates and regretting it
but i don't care because
these are my life choices and i own them
so thank you so much for
that we're watching enough to see you
again tomorrow we'll
i'll be your valentine